cool
[Music]
all right
um this jacket is actually quite hot I'm
gonna take this off
so I thought this would be a good idea
um but I am boiling in this thing
okay
um so
I'm here
to tell you actually no I'm Gonna Leave
This on because it's cool
okay in 2010 well 10 years ago
um I was uh I was founding a company
called nojitsu and it was kind of a
Heroku for node.js
platform as a service
and over the past decade there's been a
lot of things like it but better
and uh infrastructure as a service and
platform as a service
and uh and the products built on them
they've become unsustainably complex
and the cloud is and I say this as a
veteran of devops that uh it's a house
of cards
and what's worse is that as Builders of
the web
and we've found ourselves
in a landlord-tenant relationship
but all of that is changing because
we've entered a new era of ubiquitous
Computing and we've seen a proliferation
of hardware and data and today I want to
talk about why this is pushing storage
and compute from the cloud towards a
network of peer to peer
and because this isn't a prediction talk
I'm actually going to show you a
framework I'm actually going to show you
a new runtime
and
I'm also by the way not the first person
to have this perspective Peter Levine
from uh Andreessen Horowitz did a really
great talk entitled the end of cloud
computing in 2016 and then in 2019 he
doubled down on this thesis
delivering a really great keynote at the
a16z summit so here we go all right so
Computing what drives us toward or away
from decentralization or from
centralization
um in the beginning everything was
centralized
right and they would centralize for a
reason computers were the size of a room
and the upside was is that a few million
people were computing
but the downside was that
a few million people is relatively few
people but clearly there was a demand so
the cost of microprocessors went down
and we had the personal Computing
Revolution
a hardware sales boomed and suddenly two
billion people were computing
and uh this was good this was great
people were very happy hardware sales
boomed but uh there was a new problem
which was that sharing data was really
difficult
okay so we took a swing back towards
centralization it was distributed but it
was highly asymmetrical right somebody
said basically okay I'll plug in a
computer I'll turn it on I'll make sure
it's always on we'll call it a server
you can pay me to access it and it'll be
a hub and the upside to this was that
you know we figured out a pretty
reasonably good way to share data it was
intuitive and it made sense and then
information access sales boomed right
you had AOL you had you know companies
like this that were all about
information access and selling it to you
uh the problem was that there was growth
right this was the.com Era right and uh
you know everything was booming
uh but servers were the bottlenecks
right
so we took a swing back to
decentralization to peer-to-peer this is
the peer-to-peer era
the
2000s
and um this was really caused by this
this quest to find protocols that scaled
right you had Limitless access that
scaled really well millions of people
were sharing petabytes of data
peer-to-peer proved itself as a very
robust and great protocol
um Infamous products like Napster
Nutella Network BitTorrent all of these
things became household names
all right
but the problem was is that you know 80
it's the 80 20 power rule kind of
applies here right 80 of peer-to-peer
model is very hard to wrap your head
around right versus client server
um and you know sure once you get to
that 20 uh it scales really well
um it's easy to maintain but all of this
was tribal knowledge right and this is
the pre-ghub era so very few people knew
how peer-to-peer worked
um copyright holders were also extremely
upset
uh users expected everything to be free
everybody was panicking nobody knew how
to get anybody to pay for anything and
so we found ourselves going uh taking a
hard swing back to centralization uh and
this is really where we have Peak cloud
computing
um Cloud platforms like AWS enabled
people to build things like they
couldn't before nobody had data centers
nobody knew how to do this correctly and
Amazon said okay we'll rent you the
infrastructure and uh we'll handle the
hard parts for a price and Amazon did
really well with this and entrenched
everybody
and every half the internet or more is
built on AWS
uh and uh everything became a service
so here we are in the era of everything
as a service
the upside is that improved ux and
subscription-based access which
investors love uh made it possible to
ask users for money again we'll give you
all the content in the world for only
ten dollars a month
um and uh copyright holders are really
happy with this
men in the middle business is booming
um the problem here is that devops is
become insane and uh you know devops is
a really it's we're it's a house of
cards this whole situation and worst of
all uh like I said it's a it's really a
rent extracting model
everybody's dependent
on the cloud but there's something
taking us back
very quickly
to decentralization and
that thing is
we want Computing everywhere
we find a use case for computing in
almost every corner of our lives right
and because of that we're seeing a
proliferation of hardware and data we're
entering the era of ubiquitous computing
okay
controversy
how do we compare AWS to all this
Hardware that we're surrounded by
suddenly well you can't really compare
it uh specifically uh there's some
nuances to how you compare it uh it's
not a one-to-one relationship the desire
for ubiquitous Computing has driven this
Hardware proliferation but we need to
put it into perspective as technologists
trying to find utility in it right so
today there's about seven billion people
in the world and there's about 15
billion mobile devices and that doesn't
count you know 2.5 billion laptops and
the countless iot devices that exist
we're just talking about mobile devices
here
so let's look at AWS so AWS has about 38
data centers and 87 availability zones
uh 27 regions and James Hamilton said
most Amazon data centers house between
50 000 and 80 000 servers so that's
about three million servers
um and so clearly there's more
uh there's more Hardware outside the
data center than in any data center
combined
but how is it fair to compare any of
this I mean AWS Services they're always
always on mostly always on uh they're
really robust servers so the only way
that you compare this
is
um on average the individual Hardware is
unreliable it's online less frequently
and it's statistically less powerful
people have different uh battery levels
people are have different security
settings we consider all of this
Hardware unreliable but uh individually
a device doesn't replace a server it
doesn't run down battery acting like a
server and it doesn't run up CPU acting
like a server instead individual devices
make small contributions that constitute
a larger more robust Network
of course all of this Hardware
proliferation is an opportunity and it's
leading to data proliferation
basically we're creating an insane
amount of data and it just gets more
insane
um the velocity and the volume of data
creation and consumption
is a Big Driver back towards
decentralization so you probably heard
you know the self-driving car generates
10 gigabytes per mile and like you know
uh some cameras generate 300 gigabytes
of data per second
sensors are popping up everywhere right
there's sensors in everything and almost
everything in the world is generating
some data about the world around it and
then we want to do something with that
data we want to do something with that
data where like close to where it's
being actually created
um
so we want to create process and
replicate that data as close to as
possible to where it's being created but
you know a good example is a
self-driving car doesn't uh want to send
data all the way back to the data center
to avoid a potential obstacle zero
latency is Affordable in that case
Medical Data should stay private on
premise in a hospital hospitals should
be able to connect directly to each
other a lot of pressure can be taken off
for example Uber's servers if the rider
can connect directly to the driver right
so this stuff is pretty obvious but the
question is is like
you know is is how is it possible
um
so round trips to the data center make
less and less sense but another driver
that's really important that's you know
something that's driving us towards
um
decentralization is the cost and the
complexity of building uh Services cloud
services and building on top of
infrastructure as a service and platform
as a service
um
growth so as your application
grows as you have demand
in Engineers end up bending over
backwards to accommodate this
and the fact is is that a cloud gets
more expensive more complex and less
reliable with growth that's a fact and I
don't think there's anyone here that
would agree with that or disagree with
that
um peer-to-peer gets less expensive
maintains the same complexity
and of course it becomes more reliable
as your network grows
so a lot of companies are seeing
peer-to-peer as a potential for uh for
for supplementing their existing
infrastructure
or escaping it entirely in some cases
so we saw these key drivers that are
pointing us towards decentralization and
that's hardware proliferation data
proliferation
and cost complexity
and uh this is really what's going to
drive the next decade of computing and
this is going to be what we spend our
time solving problems for so we started
a company to solve some of these
problems
um we're early kind of like we were
early to node like we were early to the
web like we were early to all these
other things
um make it possible for the average
developer to build peer-to-peer apps
using HTML CSS and JavaScript
and then also provide tools to help with
that at scale
um what we were looking for was a
fundamental Improvement
I think that
um for example in the JavaScript space
there's a lot of competition for fast
servers
they're all incremental improvements of
each other we call this horizontal
progress right all these Solutions are
racing to be slightly faster or maybe
ergonomically better
um but what if apps could just
communicate directly to each other
better and faster servers really kind of
lose their meaning and and they become
less important as uh we have more direct
transactions between applications so
with peer-to-peer the responsibility
becomes distributed
and users own the hardware
and they take a degree of responsibility
for participating in the network storage
compute network connectivity
um and so what we want really is to just
remove as much of the cloud as possible
without sacrificing any performance or
reliability
or security
and in order to do this we realized what
we needed was a new runtime
so servers are ideal for super Computing
tasks and browsers are great exclusively
for client server apps
um
and there's a lot of reasons why they're
not great for building software but sock
is a runtime that is for distributed web
apps so native apps built with the web
stack
uh and it provides things that the
browser just can't or won't right so
local first capabilities right we want
Bluetooth we want to not have to use
internet in adjacent with for adjacent
devices
um so peer-to-peer makes sense
um but how do we unlock its potential
how do we what does this runtime look
like
um I'm probably preaching to the choir
when I say this but you know obviously
it makes sense to be aligned with the
web here the web has the largest most
active Community the best documentation
biggest backers easiest to staff for you
know
uh well enough patterns well-known
patterns that uh it's easy to iterate
really quickly building software and
much easier than a lot of other
platforms Maybe
okay
so
what does this look like
well
this is about as simple as it could get
so
um you can write some HTML you can write
some JavaScript you can run the build
tool and it will encapsulate your code
in the runtime and then it'll build it
for mobile or desktop
and you can bring your front-end
development framework the one you like
the best react review or preact or
svelte or whatever people are building
with today or tomorrow
um
and
um
that's about as simple as it gets uh so
I guess the question that probably a lot
of people are saying when they see this
is like well this is kind of like
something I've seen a little bit like
something I've seen
um
and the question is why not electron why
not phone Gap well obvious reasons
phonegap only runs on mobile it's also
ancient
electron is uh has quite a few valid
criticisms about its uh distribution
size and its memory footprint our
binaries for desktop clock in at uh or
weigh in at about 1.5 megabytes
that's it
and uh on iOS I think we're building it
about 13 megabytes and
um on Android about the same or less
actually
um
so some of the things that we wanted to
do of course was run on on you know all
the major desktop platforms but also the
mobile platforms we wanted to build in
packaging build packaging for electron
is like got too many options and it's
just doesn't make any sense
um you know we also wanted to make the
back end optional and we can because
we're exposing these apis like file
system in the browser polyfilling the
the apis that don't exist yet or we
don't think do the job
um
and then we also expose UDP and
Bluetooth so you get these peer-to-peer
and local first capabilities
and JavaScript node node developers will
feel right at home here because our apis
are almost well they're compatible
um so the other thing was like okay so
we built this runtime that you know
allows you to build cross-platform uh
Native applications using the web stack
this is very cool
um did we have to boil the ocean and
also build the peer-to-peer libraries on
top of it well
there's some other peer-to-peer
libraries that exist and uh they have
some reliability concerns and we
realized that when we were when we were
testing them uh because you know we
can't go to customers and say hey
replace some of your cloud or all of it
with something that we can't
quantifiably with empirical evidence
make claims to so what we decided was
that we needed to have a specification
and it needed to be informal and it
needed to be formal so
um
I think a specification
separates hobbyists from scientists
and personally I'd rather debug a couple
hundred lines of a specification than a
couple hundred thousand lines of a
distributed system that is incredibly
difficult to reason about
uh and passing passing tests and GitHub
stars and all of that kind of stuff it
really doesn't matter unless you have a
specification that can be proved
um so take a detour really quick
and I'm going to
um
put my browser over here and I'm going
to
go to this document so my co-founder
Dominic Tarr and I have been writing
this specification
and it's for Nat traversal and so some
of you may or may not know what that
traversal is but it's essentially the
most important part of connecting peers
together in a peer-to-peer Network and
um
I think that it's time
where is it
oh my God
change visibility
should I do it
oh I have to type it out
what's it called
oh good idea
we have a we
we have a stack Overflow user in here
[Laughter]
okay maybe that's it okay I can't see it
on my screen over here so
oh it's not gonna let me paste it is
okay
oh
okay okay we can do this
oh
this is what we want
paste
okay luckily we have this ability to
okay
visibility is already public
okay
okay so that's a natural spec okay now
we still have some other things here
okay so
um
okay so so that's a spec so we want a
spec now that's the informal spec so
what we've been what we've been doing is
we've been working on the
um
the the formally verifiable part so if
anybody's familiar with TLA plus uh
that's what we're working on right now
uh it gives you a way to mathematically
formally verify the states of things so
I have an initial State and I have
following states and all those States
can be enumerated and then you can have
a deterministic distributed system and
that's really important because the
cloud isn't deterministic or formally
verifiable because it's all behind it's
all private we don't know what it does
um okay so that's the NAT traversal spec
so the internal kind of high level
overview of the runtime is that you know
we basically we take libuv uh right now
just a small subset of libuv to do these
basic things that we need to do like UDP
and uh we bridge that to the operating
system component called the webview
webview historically wasn't very
consistent but now it is
um and so this allows you to basically
get exactly the same uh rendering across
all of the platforms and you know gives
you these nice Primitives like a correct
file system access and uh you know a a
complete uh networking stack
um so like I said all of the apis are
um really quite inspired by node
um in fact pretty much compatible
um
and you know I just want to like briefly
before I run out of time I have two
minutes um talk about security so
electron bad idea node in HTML went
sandbox so what we're trying to do is
bring together the best parts of the
security of the web and combine that
with the best parts of the security of
the desktop and the capabilities of the
desktop and mobile so sandboxing is
super important and then obviously
there's some things to follow along you
know to not be
um uh to not make some big mistakes and
we have guides uh on the
um on the documentation here so uh
there's guides over here for building
things and then really quickly
um
I want to try to just show
here's my terminal but I won't be able
to look at it so I'll have to
kind of here's here's the code
um you know what let's let's open source
it
okay
uh
okay that's not the right one
uh
we want this one
socket
okay so here it is
uh it's in Alpha but
I think it's ready no more no more
really significantly big changes
we're gonna make a public
and we're gonna
copy and paste this
okay it's open source
[Applause]
all right
um so
uh I have 14 seconds left okay well if
anybody wants I'm gonna do demos for
each and every single one of you I'm
going to show you how to use it if
you're interested so come and find me
and uh we'll build peer-to-peer apps and
we'll escape the tyranny of the cloud
thank you